this is my favorite way okay oh I want
you to think back both of these methods
so far they've kind of been riding on
this guy right do you see that they all
started a formula I'm here I had to work
out what a are and how many times they
work and then I just substituted in here
I twist it around the formula a little
bit until I could put in what I already
knew they use this as the starting point
what if we didn't start there where else
could we possibly start where did that
formula come from anywhere how did we
get it in the first place what do we do
modified al yeah we took we took the
general series right the sky and we did
some algebraic tricks to it in order to
get a whole bunch of terms to cancel out
and then we rearrange to make S sub n
the subject do you remember that ok now
what algebraic tricks did we pull there
was one particular basically the first
line that sort of let everything unfold
what did we do next after we wrote down
this year multiplied over we multiplied
by the common ratio do you remember that
because what she asked sub n in here you
can take the difference of these two
lines and then you get something nice
and magical like sir ok now there's
nothing stopping me doing that back with
this series because I know what r is
it's very easy to work out what r is
unlike counting the number of terms so
I'm going to say let's multiply the
whole thing by r which is minus 3 as
we've noticed employed the previous
times resolve this question if i
multiplied by r what are we end up
getting what is this first term tenant
so it certainly gets a negative right
it's already got three DM I'm going to
give it another three which turns into
three near plus one does that look
familiar of course it should it's the
second term that's the way it worked
over here right what will the next term
beer it'll be this guy the double
negative cancel which means pause and
then that M plus 1 turns into n plus 2
does that look familiar of course it
should
and I'm going to get all of these guys
in here now this is where our series
ended before but i've multiplied
everything x minus 3 right so i have one
last term on the end namely 3 m3 n plus
1 does that look familiar it should
right okay now what did I do in my
general situation right in order to get
this thing to collapse I will you either
out of your subtractors you really just
say spaces so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take a label but I let it
take line one and i'm going to subtract
line to do you see what i'm going to do
that by the way i won't just want
positives really so if i subtract
negative 3 everything will become
positive alright so what's s take away
negative 3 s double negative 4 s yep now
this is the term guys start with right
all of these terms over here will be
eliminated all of them right except
which term the first term I he's my lone
survivor G remember that right so 3 to
the N he's still sticking around and
everything else vanishes okay then i
subtract now what you subtracted this
guy and all of these guys collide with a
PR except for one which why must the
last term right now don't forget i'm
subtracting kid right you see i'm
subtracting here my gosh so it's a
double negative so that becomes a
positive yeah you know what I'm going to
be super lazy and I'm just going to say
for you can get on over there BAM
okay question let me just rehearse that
one more time and if a question comes up
you can present to me what did i do what
did i do i did i shud suppose i should
write it over here on the side so you
can see what I'm doing I did line one
takeaway line two yeah so I did s take
away minus 3s which is how I got four is
here then I saw I'm taking away this
from this this guy there's nothing
subtracting nothing to pair with him so
everything else goes except for him what
I'm subtracting is this guy right every
one of these terms has a counterpart in
the line above except this new one right
so what I get left with is this one
takeaway that one and the double
negative means a plus that's just the
next is written there and because i had
a 4 over here i just dividing him to
make s the subject okay oh yeah yeah in
fact one of the reason one of the ways i
solve this question the first time I
story is I went through all three ways
to say it did I get the same answer and
I did provided provided i don't make me
off by one errors by the way that's one
of the great things about this right
there's the accounting involved no
counting um you just you go back to you
go back to did you understand where i
got this from right and we usually use
this because it saves time but you don't
have to write it's just like oh we've
learnt the quadratic formula right well
who quadratic form is awesome but where
do we get the quadratic formula come
from we've got from Cliff Lee in the
square and Tom sometimes completing the
square you just you might as well just
do that rather than what you the result
that you got out of it okay it's good
guy that's far so it's less error-prone
what would you call that we said this
was from the formula we said this is by
using the last term why don't you name
her awesome
use our crew elimination using the
ratios um what I have the elimination
wow that's you never fail to bring the
awesome bill um honestly in my head in
my head you can call this whatever you
want honestly elimination is fine I
think it's a good because that's what
actually happens in my head what I'd
take advantage of is where I got this
from right the principle which this is
based that principle is what I've used
here so I honestly call this using first
principles this is the principle you use
to get this formula